lady so high level things apart
I'm not they're not accept that humanity
goes where ancestral hair
well but this is a great complicated
organism about time over the simple
thought let me finish this conversation
that's fine I know you can help how do
you know universal common ancestry is
true I mean that's what I believe
for example I think about being open to
logic and design I believe none of you
but not none of you because I do believe
because none of the beliefs I ever set
in stone and unchangeable zero I'm happy
to I'm happy to if I find if I presented
evidence again I will point the fact
that lives that we have evolved from
different ancestral lines then I'm
willing I'm a bit confused when I first
came here your level of certainty was
there now you're saying it's a belief
yes right now if you're gonna come to
speaker's corner here yeah like we do
with everyone you have to give evidence
if you're gonna make a claim so what is
your evidence to support your claim
what's my claim I'd even make up exactly
I'm here to challenge your claim you
cannot slip the burden of proof on him
when you're making the claim okay and
the other thing is you said it was a
belief now you do realize that's
religion
Darwinism is actually a religion which
started off as a scientific theory
because in our religion and the proof is
in the pudding
this man here and you both of you
believe in this we have no evidence for
it
250 years of saying go ahead give me
some record okay
disregard that no no hang on the fossil
record is a subfield in biology jashub
you can't say in evidence is the fossil
record how is the fossil record okay how
do they show that you'll find creatures
from around 5,000 years ago I found more
and more you'll find creatures for more
and more longer ago okay and you find it
that you like the more you dig deeper
you'll find more simpler creatures which
represent the things that which is
evolved into okay you do realize
Darwinian theory believes that there is
no inherent progress okay so random
mutations are random in respect to the
organism so there's no such thing as
directed mutations so according to
classical Darwinian theory and you can
pick up any book on this going to be one
reference philosophy of human evolution
should publish by Cambridge University
just in 2013-2014 it makes it clear
there's no such thing as progress in
Darwinian evolution for example you more
no more your normal complex then
bacteria for example you survive and you
reproduce bacteria survives and
reproduces around four billion years
very pretty complex
now you're contradicting yourself our
bacteria are are they as complexes us
bacteria that have been involved well
for billion years and some some extent
they are they're not they're not as
complex creatures but they have complex
survival mechanisms yeah okay it depends
on the selection do they survive and
reproduce yeah okay do we survive and
reproduce so according to and we just
give you this right because you guys are
not contradicting yourselves now you're
contradicting mainstream secular
academics for example Henry G in his
book The Accidental species
misunderstandings of human evolution he
says we earn and he's a Darwinist we are
no more complex than bacteria right
according to Darwinism so you can't you
can't come here and say say we are more
complex
we are not according to you according to
your worldview it's not me by the way
this is this is Darwin a system this is
different this is domination this is
dominant because now the core III see
the I see what you mean by the statement
that we're now complex because at a
fundamental level our bodies and the
bodies of bacterias are very very
similar mechanisms okay now you're
thrown into something known as homology
okay homology is the claim that
similarities are due to common descent
okay okay this is how they look at
chimpanzee and a human being and they
say because of similarities they must be
I'm gonna speak to one person at a time
you know what your French is homology
okay
now there's some issues with homology
number one you need to understand
homology is an assumption okay it's not
something which is based upon concrete
observation secondly we know the
counterfactual to this assumption of
homology known as hell more pleasing for
example there's genes in your body which
develop to let you see trip for you to
have eyes likewise there's genes in the
octopus which are there to help it see
but these are known as home or place yes
genes they're not due to common descent
so homology is something which is an
assumption which has a counterfactual to
a known as
lazy plus to rectify that discrepancy
what you have to do is you have to put
together a probabilistic framework based
upon Bayesian probabilities with nine
mathematical assumptions and then you
come to what would be considered an
approximation based upon assumptions and
conceptual problems all the divergence
between different species hang on a
second the same way that a plat swing is
I assume that a bad swing came from the
same thing as a bird's wing note
fulfills the same function no no but the
thing is that's not due to comment
descent those streets are not yeah
because they have evolved at different
points after those species have already
yep so your initial point about homology
yes but then then you go back yeah then
you go back even further so let's say
let's say you have let's say you have
different ancestors so my my basic claim
the thing that I find the most incorrect
so I'm saying that the thing that I find
the most incorrect and it's it's a view
it's not really an opinion it's the fact
that people thinks them to think them
tend to think themselves so much better
than all other creatures on this planet
because they have been given life by by
by Allah by God by Yahweh by two things
here number one we're speaking about
your initial claim of universal common
descent yes okay what I want you to get
to the bottom of and the claim which are
making and if you don't challenge it we
can move on to the next topic about
whether human beings are special or not
is that as a belief and you have no
evidence for it
because if you're going to move the
topic away either you're implicitly
implying you don't have evidence for it
or you just want to go off onto a
tangent so I can make a statement
I personally you believe it with me at
the moment right now do not have however
many pieces of scientific research that
were carried out and I cannot quote them
off by heart you obviously have an
immense breadth of knowledge on the
subject no I don't this is it this is
stuff we can easily find online and
that's the thing and you do you do
realize this stuff I know there's stuff
I've read about but okay can I give you
something which is just going to be a
conceptual reason why universal common
ancestry can never be shown to be true
okay I'm gonna be very particular okay
life has been on this earth for
approximately four billion years
according to National Science Foundation
and published studied last year in May
99.999 percent of species are
undiscovered no organism species okay we
don't have their fossils we don't have
the DNA we have nothing because they
came and they came in there and and
fertilization is very rare so because
something happened a very long time ago
four billion years life has been on this
earth and 99.999% of species are
unobserved any reconstruction you make
is bound to be speculative and the holes
speculative yes sheer speculation pure
conjecture were you around a thousand
years years ago or would all the
scientists if they tried to work you out
wouldn't be speculative yes
so Darwinism is based upon what happened
fer billion years ago with 99.999%
species missing so by that same logic it
is also speculative it's not an
observation it's a reconstruction of
phylogenetic relationships in the remote
past it's merely observing the things
that took place before Darwin Darwin
I'm sure you know what that will inform
the theory right on the Galapagos
Islands right well this dispute about
that but he he yeah yeah I mean thing is
look there all he did was he came up
with a way that organisms change
adaptation and before he published the
Origin of Species a Christian
creationist twenty years before him he
really published the theory of natural
selection as an Abbe de adaptational is
nothing new all he did was he made a
claim that natural selection leads the
bacteria to the elephant elites ever you
know you have this natural blind process
with no foresight and this is created
all of life on Earth and he came at a
time where Christianity was dying and
there was a need there's a rise of
secularism and from the very beginning
he got support from secularists whether
they understood what he was saying or he
they did not because he was a religious
challenge to Darwinism for example just
a few years ago jerry fodor an atheist
philosopher of science he published a
pope a book called what darwin got wrong
and what he said at the beginning of the
book and he's an atheist and he
published the book with another
evolutionary scientist and they're both
atheists and what they said is this they
were challenging Darwinism because he
wasn't making sense but they said we
realize in our industry which is the
scientific enterprise and the
philosophical community allegiance to
Darwinism is absolute whether you
understand it or you don't
okay and the proof is in the pudding
that you've come here believing and
claiming that it's true but you don't
have any evidence you've just been
socialized into accepting it okay fair
enough
perfectly so yeah so what have they
proposed instead okay
dated and proposed it they proposed what
other scientists have come up with so
they proposed evo-devo
evolutionary development biology as an
alternative okay plus there are five
alternatives that we currently have any
volusia cherie balaji which challenged
Darwinism
you have evolution my natural genetic
engineering put together by atheist
evolutionary biologist we have lamar
keaney Lamarckian evolution we have
mutation ISM we have symbiotic evolution
and we have evolution by
self-organization all of these five
alternatives to Darwinism you'll never
hear about because Darwin isms become
into a religion we are all of these five
alternatives were put together by
atheist evolutionary biologists who
don't believe in God okay yeah and the
reason why people believe it to be true
Universal common ancestry and natural
selection creating all of thing is just
because we've been socialized in just
look them up what they basically say is
the core of Darwinism is we have random
mutations and natural selection
accumulates those or billions of years
what they're claiming is mutations are
the random mutations are not beneficial
they're claiming they are directed
mutations which are changes due to the
environment so they're directed changes
natural selection is a trimming for so
say you go ahead and you know you wanna
carve the leaves
that's what natural selection does it
just trims it explains the survival of
the fittest but not the arrival of the
fittest okay and they come up with a
whole bunch of evolutionary mechanisms
which are challenging Darwinism and the
whole reason why Darwinism was popular
was this Richard Dawkins in his book the
blind watchmaker in the 1980s he says
before Darwin atheism may have been
logically tenable while you may be
logically have some some evidence for
atheism but after Darwin we became
intellectually satisfied atheists so the
reason why they're not laying any
alternative within science is because
the religion of atheism is based upon
the belief in Darwinism this is why you
never hear any of the things which I'm
saying right now if you go to academia
you'll you'll find them everywhere and
those people who challenged this in
academia who are atheist philosophers of
science a theory biologists do you know
what they call them secular creationists
because they don't believe in God so
it's the only scientific theory in
history which has become into a religion
and it's the only scientific theory in
history which has cost the lives of
millions of people
Hitler where he did is he applied
Darwinism to a social context like
eugenics yeah and who came up with
eugenics Darwin's cousin and his son is
the father of eugenics in this country a
justification
ok I believe life on this earth was
created by God ok I believe this God is
the author of all of the natural laws
that we have okay so if you can and
remember the origin of life is something
that Darwin did not really speak about
their ideas about spontaneous generation
they had all these weird ideas right now
even Francis Crick the guy who
discovered DNA write the note the
structure of DNA the double helix
structure
he realized life is so complex it cannot
have a naturalistic origin so what he
and his atheist okay and he won the
Nobel Prize he said and he came up with
a theory known as panspermia he said
life was sent down to earth on rockets
by extraterrestrial life somewhere else
in the universe in his book life itself
right and this panspermia theory is
still a viable option in science now
he's thinking extraterrestrials now I as
a religious person I say well it makes
more sense here's God than aliens
because then the question goes well who
made the aliens you just go back forever
nowadays do these huge differences
between human beings and the rest of
life on Earth
so we believe all of life on Earth was
created by God and they may be natural
processes which help it develop but
human beings are different to the rest
of creation for example classical
Darwinian theory says we're no different
to bacteria right the bacteria don't
stand around on Sunday talking about
philosophical and religious and moral
issues they just survive and reproduce
we drink coffee and talk about quantum
mechanics when monkeys are jumping
around in trees there's a big difference
between human beings and the rest of
life on Earth but the reason for that is
actually makes sense in I'm gonna for
now I haven't read up the other
evolution theory so I'll just argue for
Darwin there is a reason for that
because as we formed into the most sort
of basic human shape let's say yet the
most homo sapiens the first homeless ago
it became beneficial for us to favor
social interaction and intelligence over
physical traits
because we we outperformed the homo
homini under and by being smarter they
were bigger they were stronger they have
thicker bones they could run fast they
could survive unless poo and every
physical aspect they were superior to us
but we were smart
so we killed them all okay this there's
one thing I wanted to keep in mind so I
didn't catch your name
magic magic magic magic I want you to
explain that but remember with in a
Darwinian context our genetics our
physiology and our psychology all of
this including our behavior have to be
explicable in terms of survival and
reproduction nothing more anything that
we do has to be explained went on the
survival reproduction now this is a big
bone of contention amongst evolutionary
biologists and philosophers of science
for example we have things like religion
which in terms of evolution Darwinian
evolution don't really make sense when
you bow down like we Muslims do and pray
to God five times a day it doesn't help
with your survival and reproduction when
me and you sit around talking about
moral ethical issues or when we talk
about you know GTA 7 or whatever that
hey who got the highest scores that's
got nothing to do a survival and
reproduction so even atheist scientists
philosophers of science have realized
human social behavior cannot be
explained in terms of Darwinism because
if Darwinism was true then the selfish
gene idea would be correct so the only
reason why I would help you was to help
my own genes survive but we as human
beings we help people were not related
to we have things like hospitals which
are the survival of the un-- fittest and
you and me pay for through attacks
yes right so da Darwinian evolution
doesn't explain the vast majority of
human behavior devar and
even okay this is give me a second even
atheist philosophers of science and
evolution biologists I realized this big
problems with social dot with
sociobiology as equally so he was your
question I said you're wrong okay what
we it does explain that large okay so
how would they explain altruism
[Music]